what up space fam goals in here from
anime uproar and i'm back at it again to
discuss the latest episode of the attack
on titan final season
this episode was called assault and it
did not disappoint so make sure to stay
tuned for that
if you do enjoy seeing these attack on
titan videos and want to keep them
coming then the best thing you could do
is warhammer
smash that like button and share this
video with any attack on titan fans that
you know
if you haven't be sure to subscribe and
this is crucial hit that notification
bell and select
all or you will miss future attack on
titan videos and while you wait for the
next insane episode to drop
feel free to check out our growing
attack on time playlist where we got
videos about all the titan shifters and
their powers
all the acronyms and their powers the
titans rang from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description now without further ado
let's jump into the new episode we begin
where we left off with porco freaking
out at seeing an ackerman levi
specifically
he had aaron he was one bite away but
levi cut his draw
and saved aaron from being eaten in the
process the other survey corps members
are also coming to kill porco a titan
he's scared at this reversal
and calls them the devils of paradise
marlei and their titans are used to
people running from them
so having others attack them and even
try to kill their titans as humans must
really throw them off
luckily for porco peak's car titan comes
in with her equipment
and carrying her team members as well
who proceed to fire off shots
at the survey core with the anime i
definitely felt like there were many
survey core deaths
more than it seemed like to me when i
read the manga whatever happens
this clearly wasn't a smooth operation
we see the warhammer titan use her
powers
to lift aaron's tightened body into the
air impaling him even better this time
aaron is still holding the crystal with
the tricky warhammer titan user lara
tiber inside of it
finally the beast titan appears in this
episode marlei's strongest warrior he is
the beacon of
hope for marlei and the other warriors
who look up to him
as their captain in the meantime gabby
is enraged
just as aaron was when his hometown was
attacked by titans
and she wants to kill aaron to make him
pay zeke tells his warriors to kill them
all
and to let none of them escape there is
such a hype moment showing levi versus
zeke approaching each other
right before the intro comes on the only
thing more epic than this lead up to the
intro song is when people
smash that like button but smash like
buttons aside
this is possibly the best rivalry in
attack on titan it's so hyped that we
might get to see a rematch
here between humanity's strongest
soldier and marley's strongest warrior
we then jump to falco
who was saved by reiner's armored titan
body parts
which shielded him from aaron and the
destruction caused by his transformation
interestingly enough reiner himself is
unconscious although he looks okay
aside from the fact that his human body
is taking on armored titan
characteristics around his jaw
area clearly something isn't right as
falco points out he
should heal as long as he has the will
to live but he doesn't and that's the
problem when confronted with aaron
he actually said that he was sick of
himself and asked to be killed
he feels so guilty for his past actions
that death would be a relief for him at
this point
it is a very interesting turn you'd
hardly expect that a lack of will to
live
could play such a crucial role in the
middle of a very intense and important
battle
peak and porco in their titans go on to
protect zeke's back
so people don't catch him off guard many
survey corps members die
even if they are extras who we aren't
emotionally invested in
in this episode it was interesting
seeing peek talk so much in her titan
form and porco spoke with her too
but exited his titan body to do so aaron
tries to use his titan to bite through
the crystal but it's no use his
teeth actually break rather than the
crystal he knows that it's definitely
like annie's
and with annie's there's nothing they
know of that could break or even scratch
it
it's a very difficult situation to be in
in the middle of a battlefield but
luckily he does realize that lara tiber
is completely worn out
since he knows she could have killed him
by now penetrated straight through his
nape
if she had more juice left so although
the warhammer titan is amazing it's
clear that it's amazing hardening powers
come at a price
it runs out of steam much sooner aaron
transformed first and he's still good to
go
he actually undertakes a third
transformation to porco's surprise
and pulls it off showing how much
endurance he has at this point
unlike reiner aaron clearly has a very
strong drive to keep on fighting
he's definitely not begging to die
before he carries out his mission
in the meantime pique wants to handle
this situation cautiously from her view
marlene forces have the clear advantage
they have the home field advantage and
reinforcements are coming
while aaron and the survey corps appear
to be stranded in enemy territory porco
is less willing to be cautious but he
follows peak's lead initially
meanwhile the beast titan does his thing
by grounding and throwing
rocks at the enemy the rocks move
through the air like clusters of
high-speed bullets
at first zeke worries peak and porco
when he says
aaron is not my enemy they're like wtf
bro and i'm sure we all thought that but
then he says he wants to face his
nemesis levi
first a bit weird but maybe he feels
like levi is the priority because he is
the strongest soldier
after all we then jump to possibly the
craziest moment in this episode although
it is so hard to choose just one because
there are so many insane moments
but in this case we see the navy forces
in the water
these ships are ready to back up the
marleian side and then we see a small
boat with a lone hooded figure
riding on it the hood comes off in its
armament and the next thing you know
bam he transforms and there is a giant
nuclear-like explosion
that not only hits the boats but a good
portion of the land as well
we finally see armin's colossal titan in
this episode
and it's crazy to think that armin would
use the power to kill so many people
including children just like aaron did
jumping to porco's perspective it seems
clear to him now that this isn't just
some wacky
improvisation on aaron's part the parody
side
clearly has a plan and he decides to
move in on aaron knowing that if they
can get the founding titan then there
will be nothing to fear from the island
however that just leaves peak defending
zeke's back and amid all the confusion
of the colossal titan explosion levi
uses his insane speed to come up out of
nowhere and he takes out zeke
and his beast titan like it was nothing
it's crazy how fast it happens
before anyone can even react we're
almost not sure what we saw
he drops a bomb seemingly killing zeke
for good
and wow imagine what pique and the
others must be feeling right now they
just went from feeling like they were in
the superior position
to their reinforcements being completely
wiped out by the colossal titan and
their strongest warrior
their beacon of hope has just been taken
out effortlessly and in no time
flat it wouldn't be a surprise if they
just fell apart at this point but the
fight
keeps going peak and her shooters are
the next target and sasha kills one of
them
she's clearly an amazing shot with that
rifle
before they can get revenge on sasha
peak's titan gets attacked by countless
thunderspears
and seemingly all of her riders die and
she is badly hurt
she is quick-witted though and jumps off
the roof which saves her from being
killed right away
but she's very close to death and at
least in regards to this battle another
warrior bites the dust
at the halfway point in this episode on
the informational page we're simply told
that the survey core gear got certain
upgrades which you may have noticed
these upgrades include semi-automatic
pistols and anti-titan shells clearly
they've used the time skip to
improve their already impressive gear we
then see the damage armin caused
it is crazy it looks like the end of the
world the ground is scorched hands pop
out from the debris the land is
completely leveled kids are still
struggling
under the rubble and the colossal titan
continues to march
forward armin comes out of it and is
clearly sad slash horrified to see what
he has done
he wonders if bertolt saw these horrors
too
after all he did use the colossal titan
to do a similar thing to the people of
parodies
let me know if you prefer armin's or
berto's colossal titan design
in the comments because they do have
certain differences
even though things have taken a very
dark turn in attack on titan i'm still
glad that armin now has the colossal
titan rather than bertolt but you gotta
admit it is crazy to see a character
like armin doing stuff like this and
becoming the god of destruction
which is a name marlei used for the
colossal titan power
and not a reference to dragon ball z we
also see gene about to finish off peak
but
falco begs him not to steam comes out of
the car
titan and gene misses but he's not sure
and we're not sure if it was because of
the steam
or maybe because kid falco made him
hesitate and thus missed a shot
we then go back to the crazy attack on
titan vs jaw titan battle aaron appears
to get an amazing breathtaking punch on
the draw
titan and yet you gotta give porco props
he turns a possible punch to the face
into a counter-attack where he
bites off aaron's arm in the manga he
actually crushed aaron's heart and titan
fists but here he does even better
porco is clearly doing an amazing job
against aaron's titan scratching him all
over
aaron tries to block with the
unbreakable crystal and surprise
surprise the jaw titan actually leaves a
mark
the jaw titan is the key the only known
key to breaking through
these almost indestructible titan
crystals this was crazy info for me the
first time i read it in the manga and it
made me respect the jaw titan power a
lot more
not only that though mikasa also notices
that porco's draw titan is very fast
nothing like amir's version suggesting
that porco is a very talented
shifter this combination of insane speed
and the strongest slash as you've ever
seen makes porco's jaw tight enough
force to be reckoned with
unfortunately for porco though it was
not a good idea for him to show up
because he is the key to breaking the
crystal and allowing aaron to get the
warhammer titan but more on that
in a bit we also jump to peak who is not
healing so well we are told that
unlike the armored titan the car titan
isn't known for its toughness so
although its endurance is good in the
sense that peak can maintain the
transformation for months the defense
and regeneration abilities are not that
good
this explains why they equipped the
kartine with military armor because it
is so vulnerable
we then see an airship show up to the
shock of all the marlians who wouldn't
assume
that the survey corps had access to this
kind of technology
the lights that were previously being
placed around the city serve as guidance
for the ship
hanji and armin are in there together
now along with some new characters we'll
learn more about these new characters as
we go on in the season but for now i'd
like to mention the convo where hanji
notes how crazy armin's plan
is and if he got possessed by erwin
armin hopes he did because that would
mean that irwin's strength is with him
this is a nice respectful nod to the
legend himself
erwin but also a huge compliment to
armin cool let's be real is one of the
smartest characters in the series and
comes up with the best plans
furthermore he now has access to the
colossal titan so he's definitely one of
the most
overall op characters in the series now
one of paradise's most valuable soldiers
and armin pretty much
notes that they had no choice but to
rescue aaron here because without aaron
and the others there is no future for
them although armin is not the kind of
guy who would kill if it wasn't
absolutely necessary
he feels like he didn't have a choice in
this case if he didn't
then he might have not only lost his
friend aaron but also his own life and
also the lives of all the people on his
home island
armin is a complex and underrated
character and we should not
underestimate how hard it was for him
to do what he did in this episode but
back to porco's amazing draw titan if
the survey corps didn't turn up to
support aaron
aaron would have lost against the
combined powers of the warhammer titan
and the jaw titan for sure
however mikasa did show up and after
saving aaron a bunch of times from the
warhammer titan in the last episode she
also helps him here against the jaw
titan by cutting off its legs
aaron works quickly and takes off its
arms too then he proceeds to do
something that even porco thinks is some
kind of sick
joke he shoves the titan crystal of the
warhammer titan into the jaw titan's
mouth
in order to break the crystal the lethal
and speedy jaw titan has been turned
into a nutcracker for all intents and
purposes the ultimate insult
and aaron proceeds to inherit the
warhammer titan power along with
lara tiber's blood which also contained
her spinal fluid the key ingredient when
inheriting titan powers
i honestly felt like aaron could have
taken the jawtine power 2
here pretty easily but instead he
continued to smash the jawtine's face
into the ground
until the yelling of gabby and falco
reach reiner reiner wants to die in
peace but he half-heartedly transforms
because of gabby and
falco they have given him enough will
enough of a push to transform
but notably the transformation looks
very human and incomplete
as i mentioned i think this is because
his will to fight is wavering at this
point
not giving him complete access to his
powers still though it's enough for
reiner to rescue porco this time
returning the favor from the fort slava
battle aronstein was just about to bite
through the jaw titan's nape when the
transformation occurred
but when he sighed he decided to turn
around and look at reiner instead of
just continuing to bite through it
and that is the end of this episode
possibly the best episode of attack on
titan yet
let me know your thoughts about it and
what you're excited to see next in the
preview of the next episode we do
find out that the armor titan falls that
gabby picks up a rifle and runs off
and that the episode is called
assassin's bullet suggesting that gabby
might assassinate someone in the very
next episode but yeah this final season
is turning out to be
amazing we got aaron taking the
warhammer titan power in this episode
we figure out that the jaw titan has the
power to break through
a titan crystal we saw armin's colossal
titan
and we saw levi take out the beast time
before anyone knew
what was going on and many more insane
developments
like reiner's eerily human titan
transformation
anime episodes just don't get more
action-packed than this one
and it was absolutely incredible if you
did enjoy
seeing this attack on titan episode
review and want to keep them coming then
the best thing you could do
is warhammer smash that like button
really destroy it with no mercy
ruthless air in style if you haven't be
sure to subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell and select
all
or you will miss future attack on titan
videos and while you wait for the next
insane episode to drop feel free to
check out our growing attack
on titan playlist where we got videos
about all the titan shifters and their
powers all the ackermans and their
powers
titans ranked from weakest to strongest
and much more link to that is in the
description
and i especially want to thank the
patron squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible
first and foremost i want to thank the
patron of legend the one acknowledged by
lord tuigo himself and the most donated
champion
of the world alpha sigma and are the
one-tier patrons the ones who stand atop
all clans ingrata the world acquire
respect pate heffa dr cortman rythian
emperor otaku spidey life tinel big
buddhist and tungsten tarkis
and are pro heroes here patrons the one
and only gilgamesh steelers angel crews
anatoly kazowski joel stanton very gucci
jessica kayla faun rithuande
aura alicia actor bonnie parks hinokami
and water the red haired raven florian
joanne garcia
jack watches anime fat boy games deadly
saint matthew cruz anthony schreiber
hi jinx and mr waffles thank you all so
much
if you enjoy our work you can support
more of it by going over to patreon.com
anime uproar and becoming a patron today
for as little as one dollar
if you do so you'll get your name
featured in future videos alongside
these
amazing epic people right here and
you'll even get access to our private
patron only discord where we talk about
anime life
and of course dank memes so check out
patreon.com
anime link in the description if you're
interested you can also join the youtube
channel by clicking that blue join
button next to the subscribe button
which you've hopefully
already destroyed so yeah you can
support more content that way if you
prefer
and whichever way you choose to support
us you can get the same great benefits
thanks again and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you